CONSTANT CONCESSIONS:
I’m sure you know about Microsoft’s successor
to Internet Explorer: Microsoft Edge.
But, did you know that Edge is actually powered
by Google.
And it’s not some sort of obscure connection
either, the entirety of Edge is built on Chromium
which is the open source version of Chrome.
When Google released Chromium, they were primarily
aiming to help small developers and to support
the open source community.
But, somehow, their biggest competitor has
ended up adopting it themselves.
And this isn’t a temporary solution either.
In fact, Microsoft has already tried to compete
against Google.
They of course had Internet explorer, but
the original verison of Edge was also built
on Microsoft’s proprietary engine, EdgeHTML,
and their Chakra Javascript engine.
But, this version of Edge got destroyed so
badly in the marketplace that Microsoft finally
threw in the towel and announced that they
too would switch to Chrome.
Since then, Microsoft has even gone as far
as discontinuing the legacy version of Edge,
and that itself was 2 years ago.
So, it doesn’t seem like Microsoft will
be returning to the browser engine space anytime
soon.
It’s not just the browser space that they
conceded on either.
They also gave in on the backend side of things.
Back in 2015, Microsoft ditched Windows and
started using Linux for their backend infrastructure.
Since then, Microsoft has even launched their
own version of Linux.
These two are likely Microsoft’s most notable
concessions, but this just scratches the surface.
They also conceded in the smartphone space,
the music streaming space, the Windows 8 space,
the smart assistant space, and now, even the
AI space.
Instead of trying to push an in-house version
of ChatGPT, Microsoft has decided to embrace
ChatGPT itself from the getgo.
Clearly, Microsoft has done a lot of conceding
and losing over the past decade, so is this
the end of Microsoft’s mega monopoly?
Are they going to end up as the next Cisco
or Intel?
The answer is absolutely not.
Microsoft has been doing a lot of public conceding,
but internally, they are the strongest tech
company in the world, and here’s why.
HARD HEADED:
While Microsoft’s approach may seem weak
and pathetic at first glance, they’re actually
making all of the right choices.
Here’s the thing, over the past 20 to 30
years, companies have gotten into this mindset
that they have to be present in every aspect
of your lives.
Do you need to wake up early?
You should be using an Apple Alarm on your
Apple iPhone.
Do you need to workout?
You should be using an Apple Watch to track
your workout, and Airpods to power your workout.
Do you need to text your friends?
You should be using iMessage.
Do you need to video call your family?
You should be using Facetime.
Do you need to just sleep?
Well, you should be using an Apple Watch to
track your sleep.
This trend is not just apparent on the front
end either.
These companies want to control the entire
backend process as well.
If you’re building a service, you should
be using Google’s servers, Google’s compute
engines, Google’s virtual machines, Google’s
cloud functions, Google’s databases, Google’s
clouds NATs, Google’s VPC networks, and
all of this needs to go through Google Fiber.
Basically, if a product or service has any
association with tech at all, these companies
want to a part of it.
And you can’t really blame them.
They want to constantly grow bigger and bigger,
so they’re trying to control every industry
they can think of from semi conductor design
to thermostats.
But, here’s the ironic part of it.
To truly continue growing indefinitely, the
key is not isolation.
The key is collaboration, and this is precisely
what Microsoft has come to realize.
You see, it wasn’t that long ago that Microsoft
also had this same mindset of conquering everything.
By 2000, they had hit 2 products out of the
park: Windows and Microsoft Office.
These products revolutionized not just the
computer space or even the tech industry.
These products revolutionized the entire world
permanently, and this gave Microsoft such
a massive ego.
They felt that they could conquer anything
and everything, and to some degree this was
true.
They could put out crappy products like Internet
Explorer and end up controlling 95% of the
market simply because of their influence and
control.
This false sense of superiority led them to
the email space, the search space, the messaging
space, the video conferencing space, the gaming
space, the music space, and who knows what
else.
But, eventually, Microsoft reached an impasse.
They kept throwing crap at the wall but nothing
was sticking.
In fact, the crap that stuck earlier was starting
to fall down as well.
Chrome was destroying Internet Explorer, Gmail
was obliterating Hotmail, the iPod was humiliating
the Zune, the playstation was killing the
Xbox, and MSN Messenger, well that was going
full on extinct.
For the first time in their history, Microsoft
felt that people didn’t actually want their
new products.
But, maybe, that was just bad luck.
So, they continued pushing.
They bought Skype, they launched Bing, and
they entered the smartphone space, but once
again, they got annihiliated.
Their stock had stagnated for 17 years, their
CEO, while a nice guy, was also a meme and
hated by shareholders, and public sentiment
against Microsoft was worse than ever.
Microsoft needed change and they needed it
desperately.
Enter Satya Nadella.
BE HUMBLE:
If you were asked if you want to be the CEO
of Microsoft, what would you say?
For those of you who want the job, you’d
probably be selling your butt off.
Even those of you who don’t want the job
would probably be selling you butt off.
After all, you only need this job for like
60 days and you’d be set for life.
But, Satya didn’t even try to sell himself
to the board.
When they asked him if he wanted to be CEO,
he replied quote “Only if you want me to
be CEO.”
Most boards would decipher this as a lack
of enthusiasm and move onto the next candidate,
but somehow, Satya would end up getting the
job, and he would spread this humble mentality
across all of Microsoft.
His first order of business was scrapping
off all of the crap on the floor.
He shutdown dozens of sectors like their smartphone
business, he replaced the worst OS of all
time, Windows 8, and he replaced Internet
Explorer with Edge.
But, all of this was to just cut the fat on
the consumer side.
Really, he didn’t even want to pursue the
consumer side.
The reality was that Google, Facebook, Apple,
and Amazon had destroyed them in this market,
and unlike Microsoft, people actually liked
these companies at least at the time.
So, Satya decided to give consumers a break
from Microsoft.
He basically made Windows and Office free
for end users and got out of their way.
In the meantime, Satya decided to attack an
up and coming market: cloud infrastructure.
At the time, AWS was really the only player
on the market, and while they were excellent,
they were also as expensive as iPhones.
So, Satya decided to focus his efforts on
the budget cloud market.
And today, Azure blows AWS out of the water
in terms of cost.
In fact, Azure is up to 5 times cheaper than
AWS.
Satya also put aside Microsoft’s pride and
started offering Linux options because that’s
what enterprise customers wanted.
For many companies, this was simply an offer
they couldn’t refuse.
A cloud platform from a reputable company
that ran Linux and was substantially cheaper
than AWS was a no brainer.
But, the cloud was just the beginning, Satya
was intent on tailoring Microsoft’s products
to the needs of enterprises.
A great example of this is Microsoft’s acquisition
of LinkedIn.
LinkedIn has become the go to place for recruiters
and hiring managers.
Satya also made the decision to ditch Skype
and build a new video conferencing solution
just for enterprises: Microsoft Teams.
And today, Teams is looking to overtake Zoom.
At this point, Microsoft is no longer a consumer
business.
In fact, consumer based revenue accounts for
the smallest portion of Microsoft’s revenue.
Last quarter, for example, Microsoft made
$16.5 billion from Productivity and Business
Processes, $20.3 billion from Intelligent
Cloud, and only $13.3 billion from Personal
Computing.
And that includes Windows, Bing, Surface Tablets,
and the Xbox.
In other words, Microsoft can shut down their
consumer business and they would still be
a trillion dollar company.
But, that doesn’t mean that Microsoft is
giving up on or exiting the consumer space
by any means.
In fact, it’s quite the opposite.
COMEBACK:
Now that Microsoft is no longer reliant on
revenue from consumers, they can hit the consumer
space harder than ever before, but Microsoft
can’t just revert to their old strategy
though.
If they do, it won’t be long before they’re
in the same position that they were in 10
years ago.
See, the key isn’t to try to replicate the
success of the iPhone or Chrome or Facebook.
The key is to build upon these hits and make
them better.
In fact, you could argue that this is what
made these products themselves successful
in the first place.
The iPhone made cell phones better, Chrome
made browsers better, and Facebook made social
media better.
The problem with companies trying to expand
to everything by themselves is that they rarely
make said industries better.
The Zune did not make mp3 players better and
the Windows phone did not make smartphones
better.
These products were simply alternatives that
companies assumed that people would buy just
because it’s associated with a given brand
and ecosystem.
This is basically the definition of what Google
and Apple are doing right now.
But, as Microsoft found, this strategy doesn’t
work forever, and that’s why they’re not
making the same mistake again.
Instead of trying to create yet another browser
and convincing developers and users to switch,
Microsoft embraced Chrome and addressed its
painpoints.
They made the browser more efficient and slashed
its atrocious ram usage.
With 60 tabs open, Chrome gobbles up 3.7 GB
of ram and FireFox gobbles up 3.9 GB of ram,
but Edge only uses 2.9 GB.
Microsoft isn’t hell bent on trying get
you to use Bing either.
You can switch your default search engine
to Google within a matter of 7 seconds.
You also get the power of the Chrome webstore
while not giving up the power of Microsoft’s
classic products like the Office suite and
Outlook, so you get the best of both worlds.
Microsoft is using this same approach when
it comes to Bing as well.
Instead of trying to force Cortana down people’s
throats, they decided to partner with something
that’s already working: ChatGPT.
And by the looks of it, people are excited
for a Microsoft product for the first time
in a long time.
The new Bing was able to get 1 million people
onto the waiting list within just 48 hours.
And it’s just a matter of time until these
collaborative moves start hitting the bottom
line.
At the end of 2021, Microsoft was able to
overtake Apple and become the world’s largest
company, but you probably didn’t even hear
about this because Microsoft didn’t do anything
particularly cool.
And I think this is really the story of the
new Microsoft: the background juggernaut.
TIME IN THE MARKET
In the end, Microsoft is no longer trying
to constantly score winners product after
product because that’s a losers game.
Consumer sentiment changes all the time, and
it’s impossible to always be the most desirable
company with the most desirable products.
But, what is sustainable though is associating
yourself with up and coming winners and just
trying to get a small portion of that pie
for yourself.
This strategy will never yield in slam dunks
because the main product whether it be ChatGPT
or Linux will always outshine what you’re
doing.
But, at the same time, you also won’t end
up like Yahoo or Aol.
If ChatGPT’s time in the limelight is over,
no worries, you have hundreds of other winners
that you also bet on.
There’s a saying in the stock market: Time
in the market beats timing the market.
Most companies are trying to time the market.
Meta, for example is trying to hit the next
Gamestop short squeeze with the Metaverse.
Apple is busy chasing after the AR, VR, and
EV markets.
And Google thinks that they can hold their
ground against thousands of new AI options.
Meanwhile, Microsoft is just investing into
the S&P 500.
It’s not flashy or particularly interesting,
but over the long term, not even Warren Buffett
is able to hold up against it.
And that’s why I think Microsoft is the
strongest tech company in the world.
Flashy products from Meta and Apple may excite
the press, but in terms of long term sustainable
growth, Microsoft is the real winners.
But, that’s just what I think.
Did you realize just how well Microsoft was
doing?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish more companies
gave up their ego, at least partly.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.